hey everyone there are several projects
and assets in the bitcoin and blockchain
industries that are aimed towards
diverse aims
that's not uncommon to come across
programs that try to address comparable
problems for example there are number of
cryptocurrency exchanges despite the
fact that each exchange's structure and
functionality differ
they all attempt to provide crypto
traders with a venue to trade their
assets in a large sense
a cryptocurrency exchange may have its
own asset that is utilized for specific
purposes on its connected exchange such
as trading platform fee discounts and
etc
and the binance exchange binance coin
bnb is one such crypto exchange asset
and that's what we are going to talk
about in this video so hello welcome to
this new video of simply learn on what
is binance
but before starting with the video do
hit the like button and subscribe to the
youtube channel of simply learn and do
press the bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
so let's start the video
let's have a look at the topics that we
are going to cover in this video
first we will explore what is binance
coin
following that we will understand how it
works
then we will dive down deeper and
explore a very interesting concept
followed by binance which is bnb burning
then we will look at the uses of the
binance coin
followed by its benefits
after that we will come across some
important factors to consider before
investing in the binance coin
and at the end
we will see the pricing dynamics of the
binance coin
the first thing that we are going to
explore is what is binance coin
so binance coin or bnb is a
cryptocurrency that may be used on the
binance cryptocurrency exchange to trade
and pay fees
as of january 2018 the binance exchange
was the world's largest cryptocurrency
exchange conducting over 1.4 million
transactions
every second
this coin is limited to
200 million bnb tokens and runs on the
ethereum blockchain using the standard
erc 20 protocol
as an incentive binance coin
users receive a reduction in transaction
cost on the finance exchange
other cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin
ethereum litecoin and others can be
exchanged or traded for bnb
now let's move on and see
how it works
bnb is a crypto asset that fluctuates in
value as individuals use and trade it
similar to other digital assets on the
market
bnb can be stored in suitable wallets
obtained from crypt exchanges
and sent directly to others for payments
and other purposes
but there is a whole working initiative
behind this process
binance layer 1 blockchain is merged to
form the bnb chain previously the
binance smart chain and the binance
chain
binance design the blockchain for best
performance when it comes to trading
on-chain when building the bnb chain and
binance dex
it is also based on this newly developed
chain furthermore bnb chain transactions
are powered by the bnb gas token which
stands for build and build previously
also known as binance coin
now bnb beacon chain and bnb smart chain
make up the bnb chain the former is
concerned with bnb chain governance
which allows bnb holders to vote and
stake their coins then it's a consensus
layer that's compatible with the
ethereum virtual machine and has
multi-chain hubs
now moving on let's have a look at the
bnb burn concept
binance uses 20 of its profit each
quarter to buy back and burn
binance coins completely destroying them
finance has consistently performed
quarterly burns the most recent been on
october 17 2020 which was 13th quarterly
burn
binance will continue to burn bnb coins
every quarter until it has purchased and
destroyed 100 million binance coins or
half of the total supply
finance coins supply is reduced as a
result of the procedure and its rarity
is affected which could affect the
assets value
binance also has a program called the
bnb pioneer burn program which as is
cases when bnb holders have
unrecoverably lost bnb and compensate
them them by reducing the amount from
the next bnb burn
now let's have a look at some of the
uses of the binance coin
the binance coin like other developing
cryptocurrencies has a variety of
applications outside of the binance
exchange including
first is trading
binance coin can be exchanged for other
cryptocurrencies on a variety of
exchanges depending on the exchange's
regulations
next is transaction fees on the binance
exchange
users can use bnb to pay for
transactions on the binance exchange and
earn a hefty discount
next we have is credit card payments on
crypto.com bnb can be used to pay for
crypto credit card bills
next is premium processing merchants can
accept bnb as a form of payments giving
customers more options in terms of
payment methods
next we have is booking travel
arrangements on certain websites bnb can
be used to book hotels flights as well
next is entertainment
now bnb is used for a variety of
purposes in the entertainment industries
from paying for virtual kits to
purchasing lottery tickets as well
next in the line is investment
binance coin can be used to invest
in stocks etfs and other assets on a
variety of platforms
and at last is loans and transfers on
some platforms bnb can be used as a
collateral for loans there are also apps
that allow users to use binance coin to
split bills and pay friends and
relatives so now that we have covered
the basics of the binance coin let's
have a look at some of its benefits that
makes it unique
starting with
quick transactions
when you trade on the exchange with bnb
you'll have access to the platform
property matching engine which can
handle up to 1.4 million orders per
second
finding the appropriate transaction is
always possible and using bnb makes it
even easier and more reliable
next is secure and trustworthy
binance already has millions of
cryptocurrency users and dealers who
rely on the platform and believe in the
security and protection aspects of this
exchange
to keep your funds safe the exchange
uses a multi-cluster and multi-tire
system framework as well as the secure
assets funds for users next is trade
multiple cryptocurrencies
you can trade more than 150
cryptocurrencies on the exchange with
bnb thanks to a rapid secure and low
cost transaction matching technology
aside from that bnb has its own trading
pair to fulfill your individual trading
needs there's no need to seek elsewhere
moving ahead is trading discount
you can also get a 50 discount on your
trading charge if you use bnb with
traditional payment methods if you buy
10 000
worth of coins you'll be charged 10
and if you use bnb though the trading
charge is cut in half so you will just
have to spend five dollars
next is
spending binance coin you can utilize
bnb in a variety of ways in addition to
having a smooth experience within the
binance ecosystem and receiving
transaction fee discounts several
service providers particularly in the
travel and hotel industries accept it
using bnb you can purchase dinner or a
new phone as well
now let's have a look at some of the
factors that you should consider before
investing in binance coin
now binance coins can be used to invest
in some icos listed on binance launch
pad program the binance exchange will
publish new cryptocurrencies and the use
of binance coins will provide a seamless
marketplace for trading a range of
virtual tokens
binance will eventually become a
decentralized binance exchanges
principle currency
the visa debit card of monaco the
world's first payment and cryptocurrency
platform and the platform's mobile app
also support binance coin
now as we are talking about investments
let's have a look at the peak at bnb
pricing and dynamics
bnb's pricing has traditionally varied
in a similar way to the price of other
crypto assets traded on the market
finance coins market capitalization has
increased over time topic 70 billion
dollars bnb was also sold for around
0.10
per token during finances ico
today the current value of bnb is 286.67
with the market capitalization of 46
billion 801 million 200 ten thousand
eighty one dollars
bnb has seen a tremendous increase in
value since its ico reaching a high of
more than six hundred dollar per coins
at time is it wise to invest in binance
coin
well if purchase join and sold at the
right times it's conceivable and its
past price growth resulted in profit
however only time can tell where the
price of bnb will go in the future
and with this we have come to the end of
this video on binance coin i hope you
enjoyed this video and learned something
new from it if you have any questions
regarding the this concept then please
feel free to ask away in the comment
section our team will reach out to you
as soon as possible
thank you and stay safe
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here